now an update on president biden's covet
case the 79 year old is in isolation at
the white house after testing positive
yesterday morning his spokeswoman and
the president himself says he's still
doing his job even though he's sick
nancy cordes is at the white house nancy
good morning
good morning nate i just spoke to the
white house covid coordinator he says as
of 10 o'clock last night the last time
he spoke by phone to the president that
mr biden still had the same mild
symptoms he had gotten no worse dr zha
says the president's prognosis is very
good he is double vaccinated double
boosted and continues to conduct calls
and zoom meetings while in isolation
i'm doing well getting a lot of work
done going to continue to get it done in
a 21 second video message president
biden sought to reassure the public as
his aides did the same president biden
is currently experiencing mild symptoms
mostly a runny nose and fatigue
with an occasional dry cough his first
positive test comes 28 months into the
pandemic at a time when white house
covid precautions have loosened
mr biden attended largely maskless
meetings in the middle east this past
weekend spent time tuesday with
ukraine's first lady and went to
massachusetts wednesday before testing
positive on thursday i tested negative
this morning i am going to keep my
schedule first lady dr jill biden has
been deemed a close contact and donned a
mask in accordance with cdc guidelines
as she visited a school in detroit keep
the faith it's going to be ok as for the
president he's now on day two of a
five-day course of paxlavid an
anti-viral drug that reduces the risk of
severe symptoms his oxygen level was
checked this morning it was normal dr
ashish jah is white house covid
coordinator has the president had to
halt any of his regular medications now
that he's taking past levin and what are
you doing to mitigate the risk from
halting those medications there are two
medicines he's on eliquis and crestor
cholesterol lowering medicine and a
blood thinner for his atrial
fibrillation they both get stopped from
the five days that he's on pax of it and
then they get restarted and it's totally
fine and pretty normal practice
we are expecting another update from the
president's personal doctor sometime
later today and in the coming days tests
will determine whether he did in fact
contract the highly contagious ba5 sub
variant which is now responsible for
about 80 percent of cases in the united
states gail
it's definitely still around the
president has now joined a very big club
thank you very much nancy